[موسيقى] لقد
كان الأمر مريحًا عندما
تولى جيان غوريلا لا علاقة لها بواجبات الأبوة لحارس
حديقة الحيوان، تشاد ستابلز،
قال ستابلز إنه بدأ في رعاية
صغير الغوريلا بعد مضاعفات مع
والدة الغوريلا وأبيه بعد
ولادته.
أنا هنا في غرفة نوم كارلوس والتي
موجود في منزل الغوريلا هنا في MoGo
Wildlife Park حيث يقضي كل
وقته الآن ولا يزال عمره بضعة أيام فقط، وقد
تم تشخيص إصابته بالالتهاب الرئوي الإنتاني حيث
توقع الأطباء البيطريون أنه لن يتمكن من ذلك، وقال
ستابلز إنه قام برعايته حتى يصبح صحيًا
مثل طفل حديث الولادة.  حتى أنه يقوم بتغيير
حفاضاته وإطعامه بالزجاجة،
سوف يعتاد الزوجان على بعضهما البعض
تدريجيًا قبل مشاركة القفص لأن
إعادة توطين طفل الغوريلا أمر محفوف بالمخاطر